Blake Lively and Mila Kunis's pregnancy  styles are on point that's actually one  of my favorite looks we are obsessed  with these two expectant moms latest  maternity looks on Tuesday Blake Wilde  in two outfits while in New York City  the 28 year old actress sported a peach  eyelid dress to the press day for her  upcoming Woody Allen film Cafe Society  and dazzled in stacked accessories Blake  slipped into something more flashy after  that he or she is strutting in a royal  blue wrap dress for a night out on the  town with her gal pals the same day Mila  Kunis looked cute and comfortable as she  stepped out for lunch in Studio City  California Mila who is expecting her  second child with husband Ashton Kutcher  kept things casual showing off her  growing belly in a gray tank top and  camouflage pants safe to say these two  mamta peas have amazing  baby bump fashion sense